[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story horror in the playground
the random knife attack that's left to
British two-year-old and three other
children in a critical condition
[Music]
s
as French police search for emotive
President macron says his nation is in
shock also tonight
captured on CCTV the moments before met
police Sergeant Matt Ratner is shot dead
by handcuffed suspect
in Ukraine the reality of a flood rescue
operation in the middle of a war zone
there is still a lot of incoming and
it's getting closer we might have to
retreat certainly a lot of the rescue
workers the few that were here have
scattered wildly
where she sunach hails the indispensable
alliance with the U.S announcing a new
agreement but no trade deal
thus an East London Victory Parade as
the Hammers bring home their first
European trophy for 58 years
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening they are the screams which
Mark the moment horror came to the
idyllics city of Anansi in the French
Alps in a small Lakeside playground a
man wearing a bandana vaults over the
fence and stabs several young children
at least one of them is still in a push
chair a British two-year-old is tonight
amongst four with life-threatening
injuries after what French president
Emmanuel macron described as an act of
absolute cowardice
it all unfolded in Southeastern France
at about 9 45 a.m at local time the city
is described as the pearl of the French
Alps
the playground is often frequented by
parents and babysitters
like correspondent Becky Cottrell is at
the scene this evening uh Becky what
more can you tell us
well this is just such a disturbing
crime toddlers some of the most
vulnerable people in society attacked in
a playground people here can't quite
believe it and they've been coming here
today to lay candles and flowers in
tribute to those who have been injured
and we understand those four children
are in a very serious condition in
hospital this community this country is
desperately hoping that they pull
through we should also say two adults
were injured in that attack too and you
should have more details on what
happened today in my report
is
a playground in an idyllic French
holiday Resort is now a sacred site for
a community in shock
hours earlier a man came here armed with
a knife and attacked four small children
incapable of Defending themselves one
victim was in a pushchair
they were toddlers between 22 months and
three years old Brave members of the
public tried to stop this senseless and
brutal assault brandishing their
backpacks as Shields before the police
seized him
macrame attire witnessed the arrest he
came back here to pay his respects with
his own children
I wasn't thinking of an attack in a
children's park right here in Anniston
it's impossible I didn't know what was
happening people were running everywhere
I asked myself what it could be and
after we were informed that there had
been an attack on old people and on
children that's the moment we really
freaked out
an athlete running in the park remembers
the chaos and distress
all of a sudden a mother said to me run
run there's someone starving everyone
around the lake you stab children run
run and I was a bit surprised I carried
on I saw the guy basically right in
front of me
the victims who've suffered
life-threatening injuries include a
young British national
31 year old Syrian man is now in police
custody
[Music]
terrorism is not thought to have been a
motive a community a country is now
asking why this happened why would
anyone do this
there have been knife attacks in small
towns in France across Europe before and
many people when I heard about this I
think thought is this terrorism we
understand as I just said in my report
that is not the case so why would this
man do it well what do we know about
this suspect
um he we understand has been living in
Sweden for much of the past decade given
Refugee status there but in more recent
months came over to France we also
understand that he is a child who is the
same age as some of those that he
attacked today and the French
broadcaster bfmtv says that he is
married to a Swedish woman they are
separated and she says that she hasn't
spoken to him in recent months we
understand they were both training to be
nurses but this man was not known to
French Security Services and he has no
criminal or psychological history that
we are aware of the fact that he is an
immigrant has sparked some right-wing
groups to comment on this case in fact
here earlier tonight there was I
wouldn't say a demonstration but a
significant Gathering of people mostly
men singing the French national anthem
and our translator told us talking about
how unhappy they were that an immigrant
had got into this country and committed
this crime we are also now waiting to
hear more details about the victims
waiting for positive news everyone hopes
about them including that young British
girl
it's an anxious way to Becky thank you
when Louis de zoyser was arrested in
London in September 2020 officers who
searched him didn't spot the antique
revolver he wore in a holster later he
used that very gun to shoot and kill
Metropolitan Police Sergeant Matt Ratner
in a police station
Ivor Bennett's report shows the moments
before and after the Fatal shot was
fired
these are the final moments before
Sergeant madritana was killed in a
police custody Center in Croydon in
September 2020. my name is Matt I'm the
custody officer I'm in charge he was
speaking to Louis de zoyser who had just
been arrested when suddenly out of
nowhere he is shot
the zoyser was handcuffed when it
happened with his arms behind his back
but still fired four shots before being
overwhelmed the prosecution believes the
gun was concealed under his armpit
Sergeant retana was 54 when he died an
officer for nearly 30 years he was near
retirement
his partner was in court when footage of
his death was played
also shot himself during the incident
and was left brain damaged his arm in a
sling he sat in the dock in a wheelchair
on trial for murder the jury was shown
the gun de soyuza allegedly used in the
shooting and was even allowed to fire it
inside Court a ballistics expert
explained it was safe to use because it
had been loaded with plastic dummy
cartridges members of the jury then
aimed it at the ceiling before pulling
the trigger
you under arrest okay
the possession of what I believe to be
bullets there's alwayser had been
arrested just before the shooting after
a police stop and search officers found
cannabis on him an ammunition but not
the antique revolver he was carrying in
a holster I'm just gonna have to put you
in handcuffs while I search you the
reason
what's the matter
so the reason for that is people try and
do silly things when we search them they
try and hurt themselves they try and
hurt police officers the 25 year old
denies murder he claims he was suffering
an autistic meltdown at the time and
that he did not mean or want to kill
Sergeant retana either Bennett Sky News
Northampton
now to Hassan in southern Ukraine where
Sky News has seen evidence that the
evacuation effort after the destruction
of the Nova kakovka dam is being
targeted by Russian forces
Sky News all residents and Rescuers
forced to take shelter as the sound of
shell fire rang through the air our
correspondent Alex Crawford sent this
report
they thought they'd fled to safety
escaping troops in russian-controlled
territory
[Music]
they've come through floods and Rapid
currents but even amidst the hugs and
sheer relief there's the unmistakable
sound of War getting closer
she keeps repeating but their Joy is
very short-lived
there's another attack much closer this
time it seems to be deliberately aimed
at this evacuation point in this Panic
the rescued and The Rescuers are forced
to Run for Cover
Alex Alex it's been incoming call now
and all the evacuation operations have
had to scatter All The Rescuers back to
scatter and just even these people just
waiting all just headed for shelters and
buildings they don't want to leave even
the smallest behind many of these people
are already traumatized amongst them
those who are trying to help during this
huge emergency
body armor was hastily put on by eight
volunteers taken by surprise
but they're attacked again
[Applause]
even as they tried to save their few
emergency supplies
there is still
[Music]
getting closer
have scattered wildly and said that's it
for today they're basically just packing
up now and they're still coming under
attack
on water it's worse
a relief effort rescuing the stranded
and vulnerable from a deliberate
flooding now being repeatedly targeted
it's hard to imagine it getting much
more frightening for these people
earlier the Ukrainian leader traveled to
the emergency area dropping in on one of
the evacuation points he's heard global
leaders to respond more quickly
large-scale Aid efforts are needed here
he says
but still the attacks continued forcing
the frail and elderly to shelter but not
crushing their determined spirit
they bombed our apartment before New
Year she tells us we've been through it
all I'm not afraid of anything anymore
and amid the attacks in her son multiple
reports of a Ukrainian push on two
fighting fronts in the south and east
sudden ramped up activity in the midst
of a flood's emergency Alex Crawford Sky
News hears on in southern Ukraine
so was it sabotage mismanagement or
Mother Nature both Ukraine and Russia
have denied responsibility for what's
been described as the biggest
environmental disaster since Chernobyl
our International Affairs editor Dominic
wagorn Enlisted the help of experts to
assess the images and the data
Tuesday sometime after 2 A.M the Nova
kahovka Dam has been partially breached
explosions appear to be ongoing note the
blast on the left of the screen and the
pylon on the right
by Dawn the pylons gone the breach has
widened much more of the dam overwhelmed
by water exactly what caused this
disaster is the focus of intense
scrutiny the answer could have grave
implications for what happens next in
this wall
so the ukrainians did it with artillery
in particular American supplied High
Mars Precision guided artillery used by
Ukraine it's believed once already to
hit the dam in November so what are we
seeing here we've seen the dam breached
the dam has been breached we've just
seen an explosion which you know is
probably a mine that's about the sort of
size of explosion uh importantly it's
gone straight up so it's not an
artillery shell there simply isn't the
evidence to suggest the ukrainians did
this with artillery Farm a deliberate
and elaborate sabotage is a much more
plausible Theory this is a very
sophisticated structure it's been
designed to hold back millions of tons
of water it's been designed so that even
if there's a small breach it won't
become catastrophic we have a
catastrophic breach here
there has been this footage of
explosions in the water near the dam
which Russians say is evidence of
Ukrainian shelling
but the smoke plume is vertical most
likely these are dislodged mines
exploding in the water ukrainians have
been warning residents about the dangers
of floating mines since the breach
happened alternatively could Mother
Nature have been responsible this graph
shows that rainfall and water levels in
the dam have been unusually high
recently did that somehow cause the dam
to fail as some have suggested
not likely says its experts on
Structural Engineering it's two sections
that have been breached in the dam
itself whether one explosion caused you
know a sort of riveting effect on the
the concrete structure itself if natural
causes can be ruled out and the
ukrainians weren't responsible what's
left is Sabotage by the Russians they
have the most to benefit as it could
delay the ukrainians counter-offensive
on this front by up to two months
that conclusion though poses an
unsettling question if Russians were
prepared to blow up a dam with all the
destruction that's caused for only
temporary tactical gain what else are
they capable of and what are they
planning next
Dominic wagorn Sky News
it's no longer the special relationship
it's now an indispensable one Rishi
sunette hailed the links between the US
and the UK in his first meeting with Joe
Biden in Washington DC today but though
he only announced a clean energy
agreement the Prime Minister refused to
accept that his government's failure to
strike a new trade deal was a broken
promise
our political editor Beth Rigby reports
from Washington well it's great to be
here thanks for having me Jim the PM in
the heart of the White House hearty
handshakes and warm Smiles it was a
special relationship in good shape Mr
President is it in good shape
a thumbs up for Mr sunac and the special
relationship these two leaders here to
talk about deeper economic ties packaged
up as the Atlantic declaration there's
no issue of global appoint of importance
none that where our nations are not
leading together countries like China
and Russia are willing to manipulate and
exploit our openness they will not
succeed
today we have agreed the Atlantic
declaration
a new economic partnership for a new age
of a kind that has never been agreed
before an agreement to ease some trade
barriers tightened defense industry ties
and share more data all with an eye on
emerging threats and on AI where the
Prime Minister wants to show leadership
a very welcome POTUS endorsement we're
looking to uh Great Britain to help lead
that effort to figure out a way through
this so we're in full total cooperation
because there's no one no country we
have greater faith in being able to
negotiate this both leaders talking up
the Atlantic declaration but that Accord
is nowhere near the full fat free trade
deal that the British people were
promised as a brexit bonus in the 2019
conservative Manifesto it was meant to
have been completed by 2022 instead that
free trade deal has been put very much
on ice
that Cooling in what is otherwise a warm
relationship undoubtedly uncomfortable
for Mr sunac that is a broken promise
I've got what you said in the manifesto
here you stood on it I think since then
we've had a pandemic we've had a war in
Ukraine and that has changed the
macroeconomic situation so you have the
British people well I think China is
with other countries I said but we've
grown our trade with America by 20 last
year 14 billion pounds of investment
supporting thousands of jobs announced
just yesterday the real challenge we
Face are the threats to our Economic
Security taking steps to forge closer
ties in a destabilized world but that
trade Deal's still elusive the UK may be
Biden's closest Ally but for this
President America comes first Beth Rigby
Sky News in Washington
meanwhile across the United States
millions of people have been told to
stay inside and only go out if they have
to a smoke from wildfires burning in
Canada in Gulfs cities and states
City particles now stretch from the
Rocky Mountains in the west to the
Eastern Seaboard from Arctic Canada down
to the Caribbean Canada's warm and dry
spring has produced extensive fuel for
wildfires as of June the 6th there were
437 active fires with 248 out of control
Philadelphia now has one of the worst
air quality readings of any U.S city
from there our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone reports
in Philadelphia the smoke sits heavy
it's hanging and only moving slowly
across a vast part of the Northeastern
United States and this is where it's
been worst through the day at the city's
airport flights were paused for a few
hours visibility was so poor
and don't assume this is just Cloud were
it not for the smoke this would have
been a blue sky day
within the city itself though it's
harder to see that the air is quite so
bad on Rocky's steps the city officials
advice to stay indoors had not filtered
through are you worried is it overly
concern you well we did look into
getting Mass the n95s this morning but
we're not that worried look actually
today looks better than yesterday even
though they said it's worse
um you know it's concerning you know
when you see the air is not clean all
the time but you know what are you going
to do about it you could either stop
your life stop what you're doing or you
know just deal with it so
I'm being careful they don't care so
you're not too worried sir I'm not
worried I never smoked for my life so I
guess I'm smoking a little bit but
the Striking thing is that you can smell
and feel the heaviness of smoke produced
by wildfires well over a thousand miles
to the north of here this is Central
Philadelphia where the air quality index
was well over 300 at one point that is
hazardous and it is record-breaking
at the city hall the health commissioner
live streamed her update spelling out
the dangers
well the scale goes to 500. so this is
terrible out of Philadelphia North
through New Jersey towards New York the
smoke persists and this staggering
Manhattan time lapse shows what New
Yorkers have experienced scientists have
concluded it represents the worst air
pollution for America in recent history
the scale of the cause the source is
just staggering from Canada's West Coast
to its East Coast forests are burning
the country is set for its worst year on
record already and we are far from being
at the peak of the season
in British Columbia Donnie Creek is the
second largest fire in the province's
history covering the equivalent of
almost 450
000 football pitches and it's growing
prime minister Justin Trudeau has
welcomed President Biden's pledge to
send many more American firefighters
North to help but some fires will
probably burn through the summer in a
time where our climate seems to be
changing so fast this is yet another
hint that the consequences of extreme
weather events impact well beyond where
they hit Mark Stone Sky News in
Philadelphia
well here in the UK an Amber heat alert
is in place with the hottest day of the
year expected this weekend and in the
Pacific another weather pattern is
brewing which could have big Global
implications let's bring an out science
correspondent now and Thomas I'm a Corsa
referring to El Nino tell us more about
it and what sort of impact it can have
well it's likely to significantly
disrupt global weather patterns over the
coming months now the El Nino effect
starts in the Pacific where every few
years the winds flip Direction allowing
warm water to Surge to the surface off
the coast of South America and this
temperature shot shows that effect in in
red as it moves into the Central Pacific
and that can have big impact on the
amount of tempo warmth being released
into the atmosphere and also the
rainfall can be disrupted over disrupted
over vast distances now that can mean
that in Australia condition are much
drier increasing the chances of
bushfires in the Indian subcontinent the
the monsoon can weaken reducing the
amount of rain for crops in Africa the
can be a failure of the rains increasing
the chances of uh famine while in the
United States the wet conditions can
increase the chances of flooding now
this is a natural effect this heat from
the Pacific but it adds to the
temperature rise from global warming and
scientists believe next year could be
the warmest on record and could take us
closer to that 1.5 degree threshold of
global warming Beyond which the climate
becomes more dangerously unstable that
heat Spike may be temporary but the
impacts are unknown indeed Thomas thank
you
cancer patients are facing
life-threatening Hospital delays that
will only get worse due to NHS staff
shortages the warning from senior
doctors came as new data shows the
number of people waiting to start
routine hospital treatment has also
risen to record highs here's our health
correspondent ashes Joshi I often think
if I've made more of a fast you know
hassle the doctors a bit more try to get
the operation sooner we wouldn't be in
this situation
John was due to have his first cancer
check in March 2020. then the pandemic
Struck it was now on impossible to to
get a diagnosis for cancer to get a
diagnosis for heart disease or you know
other really serious diseases after
years of delays in diagnosis treatment
and surgery John's bowel cancer
is now incurable
I've been told that my that my best
option is just to remain on chemotherapy
indefinitely
until it stops working effectively so
it's not much of a prognosis because
um it it does mean it will stop working
and I'll die because that's what happens
with chemotherapy but the NHS was
struggling with cancer before covid
urgent GP referrals have troubled since
2010 and over the same time Staffing
levels have increased by 50 percent but
that hasn't been enough to cope with
demand we've seen the highest number of
patients waiting more than a month for
radiotherapy treatment per year all of
that doesn't work unless it is
adequately resourced both in terms of
funding and other support and there is a
Workforce to do it due to neglect over a
decade or so we do not have the skilled
Workforce we require to provide that
Healthcare well thanks for coming along
the health center says targets to catch
cancer cases earlier are improving
survival rates we saw about 2.8 million
people last year when Health leaders say
they're also putting pressure on the
service although the numbers of people
actually getting cancer is going up
about three percent every year as our
population ages actually the amount of
cancer treatment we're giving is going
at about double that rate it's going
somewhere between five and ten percent a
year more as people live longer as
people can have more lives of treatment
and as we find new ways to treat them so
we have got a a lot of pressure in the
system John is trying to raise money for
radical vaccine therapy in Germany his
prognosis might have been very different
if his cancer had been diagnosed earlier
Sky News
the high court has heard that Piers
Morgan took an interest in Royal stories
during his time as editor of the Daily
Mirror and would inject information into
some of them the paper's former Royal
correspondent Jane Kerr was
cross-examined today by lawyers for
Prince Harry who alleges journalists
used unlawful means to gather stories
about him her byline appears on 10 of
the 33 stories written about the Duke of
Sussex between 1996 and 2010 which have
been submitted to the court
a 15 year old boy has died after his
e-bike collided with an ambulance in
Salford in Manchester greater Manchester
police said it happened on Langworthy
Road after traffic officers had been
following the boy until bollards blocked
them going further and the Collision
happened a short time later
the trial of a nurse accused of
murdering seven babies has heard she may
have done it to get the attention of
someone she had a crush on the court
heard while in fact became suddenly
unwell the two on-call doctors including
the one Lucy letby allegedly liked had
gone to the Tea Room for a quick break
she denies the charges
the city Watchdog is investigating the
hedge fund founded by financier
crispinodame as he faces renewed
allegations of sexual misconduct an
investigation by the financial times
highlighted allegations of sexual
harassment or assault by 13 women
against multi-millionaire fund manager
over a 25-year period Mr O'Day has
denied the claims
when West Ham Captain Declan rice was a
boy he'd watched triumphant as teams
returned Victorious from Europe today he
traveled through East London with his
Squad to lift their first major trophy
for decades as the community looked on
Rachel venables was on board the victory
bus
the moment they've been waiting 43 years
for
Jared Bowen's injury time goal at the
Europa conference League final gave West
Ham their first trophy since 1980 and
their first European win since the 60s
from Prague to the streets of East
London the euphoric team joined an open
top bus Parade from their old ground
Upton Park to Stratford Town Hall
thousands of fans packed the streets
climbing high and wide to get a glimpse
of their Heroes and the trophy it's a
moment Club Captain Declan rice has been
waiting for all his life I was once a
kid watching teams do Trophy paradings
and I'll be on one of them Captain aside
last night is just so so special I can't
even put it into words not hit me yet
this is
n't about for decades the Euro
conference League may only be a third
tier tournament but listen to those
cheers they
[Applause]
they are champions again I've never ever
thought in my whole entire life that
we'd be champions of Europe championship
I didn't think it will happen but today
is the big day big cup what more can we
say it is madness 50 years I've been
sporting West Ham over 50 years waited a
lifetime for this both Captain Declan
rice and Manager David Moyes Futures at
the club are uncertain but for these
fans for now it doesn't matter they are
celebrating like they haven't in decades
praying it won't be another 43 years
before they can party like this on the
streets of East London Rachel Venable's
Sky News Stratford
congratulations to them that was
Skinny's at 10 coming up we'll take a
first look at tomorrow's newspapers in
the Press preview including this story
on the front of the Metro their headline
stabbed in their pushchairs referencing
the attack on four young children at a
park in France
tonight we're going to be joined by the
editor-in-chief of the national World
Cities Newspaper group Nancy Fielder and
the Barrister and former government
Minister Anna subri do stay with us
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Sky News in just a moment the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive but first our
top stories an attacker armed with a
knife has stabbed four children under
the age of three in amnesty in France a
British child is amongst the injured
CCTV footage showing the moments before
a metropolitan police officer was shot
and killed has been released at the
trial of the man charged with his murder
Minister and Joe Biden have agreed a new
partnership to strengthen the UK U.S
relationship but discussion of a full
post-brexit Trade Agreement has been
shelved
[Music]
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the
editor-in-chief of the national World
Cities Newspaper group Nancy Fielder and
the Barrister and former government
Minister Anna subri so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
well the Metro has the headline stabbed
in their push chairs referencing the
attack on four young children at a park
in France
the sun reports that one of the victims
is a three-year-old British girl
that's also the main story for the
express
The Daily Mirror focuses on a woman who
leapt into the path of the attacker to
try to stop them
the telegraph leads on Ukraine saying
the long-awaited counter-offensive has
begun
the eye describes Britain and the U.S as
rewriting the special relationship with
the newly agreed Atlantic declaration
but the guardian points out that Rishi
sunak didn't get the free trade deal the
government wanted
the male asked whether NHS patients have
the right to know if the doctors
treating them are transgender
bft reports that the financial conduct
Authority is to expand its investigation
into claims of sexual assault at the
hedge fund OD Asset Management its
founder Crispin Odie denies the claims
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Nancy Fielder and Anna subri welcome to
you both we start with this shocking
um story front page of the Metro that
the stabbing of the children and two
adults in France
atrocious Nancy
yeah it's hard to find words isn't it
when stories are just this awful I mean
the footage you've shown every single
image it's a man who calmly walks around
with a huge knife in his hand and
deliberately targets babies they're
babies aren't they some of them presumed
they could barely walk they were in push
chairs and they've got serious injuries
they're fighting for their lives now and
I just think how horrific it must have
been for everybody involved you can kind
of see there's one one with a posture
and what could you do there is nowhere
to go how do you even defend a baby
against things like that you shouldn't
even have to think about it and it's
such a beautiful place such a picture a
background and I think it's rare that we
come across I mean there's a lot of bad
news in there out there but this is
absolutely horrific a knife man who
delivered the targets babies when
they're in a playground with no defense
yes I mean it's just truly shocking and
um we saw one woman was seen on video
desperately desperately trying to
protect her child Anna
exactly
um and you know you take your children
to a playground to have fun and you
think you're going to be safe uh and as
Nancy says Anna see which
um some of your viewers may know it it's
on the route to for people uh when
they're going on holiday in France
either if they're lucky enough to go
skiing or in the summer or other times
it's a beautiful place and to think of
something as horrific as as this
happening especially in a playground
when you're on holiday absolutely
Dreadful and we can only have our
thoughts and prayers with the families
of those little ones in particular and
hope that they are not going to be too
seriously injured and they'll all pull
through and be all right yeah so there
definitely will be in our prayers and
the sun
um pointing to the fact that that one of
the the children is actually a British
girl that was on holiday at the time
Nancy
yeah I mean presumably they've got very
young children you can go on holiday out
of school holidays can't you they've
gone somewhere for you you just never
think that something like this is going
to happen and it must be just as
horrendous for the families back home
trying to work out what is going on when
you when you've got
a young child a grandchild over there in
in this situation I mean it is I think
we can all picture we can also start to
start to put yourself in that situation
and you just don't know what could you
possibly do there are a few things as
horrific as this and it must be awful if
everybody back home as well as I mean
the whole area must be absolutely
shaking in France yes we spoke earlier
to our correspondent
um who's there for us and and she was
saying that uh well certainly at the
moment police are not
um
saying that it's terrorism related
they're not seeing that as a motive at
the moment Anna
yeah
um look this man apparently is a Syrian
refugee being granted asylum in uh I
think in Sweden in any event he was in
France he's apparently a Christian none
of these things I personally think are
particularly relevant but unfortunately
whenever we have a tax like this which
seem to have absolutely no logic no
motive whatsoever in a wooden Earth
possesses anybody unless very profoundly
mentally Disturbed to do such a heinous
thing or we assume more we certainly
explore that perhaps it's it's linked to
terrorism uh we're told in this case
it's not
yes sir we shall um see obviously it's a
developing story and police still
carrying out investigations
um let's move on to um politics
International politics Nancy and Britain
and the US rewrite those special
relationship these details coming out of
the news conference that Rishi sunak
held with Joe Biden in the States this
evening
yes so there are big smiles big hand
snakes how much has actually been
Rewritten um who knows but both of them
are very very
clear that it's a special relationship
that they've got really good deals here
but actually if you pick through the
detail it's fairly scanned it's
certainly not the incredible
life-changing deal for the country that
was talked about way before the brexit
vote it's a series of
I think one of the paperless Garden sort
of mini deals and it's good it's a
positive step forward but I think we
could possibly make too much of this um
the most the most powerful thing I think
is them sat together there's the hands
Nick there's the smiles unfortunately
Biden says he still likes us and we've
still got a relationship like no other
Anna what's your thoughts on the
Atlantic declaration
foreign
as as we've heard it looks like it's as
uh I don't think it's even many deals I
think it's just agreements that we'll
work on things like Ai and a lot of the
of the thinking behind this is that we
can cut China out of the supply chains I
I don't have any problem with that
because of our over Reliance uh it's
well there's a really strong base that
we are overly reliant on China uh and
you know they what we all know the
difficulties with China and and there's
also a view that we're also beginning to
reduce the importance of Russia when it
comes to trade so anything that
strengthens our relationship with our
colleague with our friends of America to
me is a good thing but my real takeaway
is as nursing research was saying is to
do with brexit I mean we were promised
that we would get this amazing deal
um with America we were told in fact the
conservatives but since 2019 Manifesto
but we were going to get that deal and I
think that the awful Donald Trump said
that that was possible and those of us
that were opposed to brexit said this is
a load of old nonsense this is just not
going to happen you know you're
basically being lied to and come to you
don't get trade deals with a country
like America like that as we were
promised and I have to say we've been
proved right and yet again we see a
promise that was made about the benefits
of brexit being badly broken but at
least this is a good thing and I think
it's a good thing for our country uh and
it would be even better if we picked up
some of the policies that buying that
about having a strategy that uh on our
industrial strategy or business strategy
that is looking at how we can really get
growth from some of these green
technologies
and Nancy that that's the the point that
the the Guardians making that exact
point that um
soon act didn't get the trade deal that
he wanted in the Zana says that was
promised in in the manifesto
yeah and I mean they put it across as a
very negative thing don't they are
packed with Biden as hope of trade deal
vanishes it is a great example of how
different stories can be spun depending
on your political inclination as a
newspaper editor
um but yes I mean the the deal is not
big
um but it is a deal and it's positive I
mean there are all sorts of jokes that
actually there's some most senior people
in America can't even remember our prime
minister's name because it's sort of not
in their faces he's not there enough
which is a concern but there is um we've
got the image we've got these we've got
positive steps forward and it will be
fantastic actually if Biden's serious
that we should be leading the way
instead of supporting
um economics around climate change and
what we can do to sort of Auntie fossil
fuel and technology that would be
fantastic I don't see much of it
happening but I would love it to happen
so that could be a really positive thing
and one question about the lack of a
wider dealer sinner consisted the
Declaration would benefit British
companies and respond to the particular
opportunities and challenges that we
faced right now and into the future uh
let's take a look before the break at
the the Telegraph and that the key of
counter-offensive has begun we read Anna
yes let us hope that this is the
beginning of a huge push Now by Ukraine
to regain their land
following the appalling and unlawful
Invasion by Russia and we know that well
we know that Russia has continued to
commit the most appalling war crimes by
it looks like you know it's a lot the
logic tells us that they must be
responsible for the blowing up the dam
and the appalling flooding that we are
seeing and here now is uh the the
wonderful zelenski
um in hershon forgive me if I pronounced
that incorrectly and and the emerging
story of course is what the Russians are
now doing having breached the dam of
caused this terrible flooding uh it
seems that they're now actually
um terrorizing bombing people fleeing
from the floods but what the telegraph
is saying it's there and splashed on
their front page is that this love
awaited and we hope it to be final
offensive has at last begun and I think
all of us would wish the ukrainians
every success and we must continue to do
everything we can to support them a lot
of their Weaponry has quite properly
been has been supplied to them by
countries like ours and we should all be
really pleased about that and and
congratulate the government for what
it's done
Anna and Nancy uh thank you very much
for the moment we are going to take a
break stay right there
coming up the Prime Minister misses his
Target on NHS waiting list we'll discuss
that and more next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
evacuation you must leave for many
people Harvey is far from over
Christchurch has been changed Forever by
what happened here there was a river of
blood coming out of the mosque that's a
scene that you don't forget
Ida has certainly left its mark on New
Orleans it feels heartbreaking
we help you understand the world with us
[Music]
we are standing on the supply line right
into the heart of America's opioid
crisis
I've reported from around the world and
around the UK are you trying to run me
over so Philip no go away look like it
sir
will you respond to those who've made
accusations so Philip can you go away
Joe Biden knows the celebrations are
over and this is a country in crisis
you don't want to be remembered this way
you always want to be remembering
something positive
it is almost impossible to predict where
these fires will go next
[Music]
this gives you an idea of the strength
of those winds strong enough to bend and
twist metal
do you regret the Tweet Gary there's no
sign publicly at least of either side
being willing to give ground
[Applause]
how do you reassure the public
that all of these mistakes wouldn't be
made again I'm Greg mylam and I'm Skye's
Chief north of England correspondent
[Music]
I
thank you
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Nancy Fielder and
Anna subri let's take a look at the
Metro we're going to go inside the the
metro and this story about NHS waiting
lists the awaiting list for routine NHS
hospital treatment including knee and
hip operations has hit a record 7.4
million in England this comes months
after Rishi sunaka vowed to cut that
list
Anna
yes
um I was reading this story
um in detail
because it's not just the fact that the
uh waiting lists as the headline says
that 7.4 million people waiting for an
OP
um with this promise from issue sooner
really now under real pressure as to
whether or not he's going to be up to
deliver on that when you actually dig
right into that story there was a number
of things that struck me now we we know
from the reports today that cancer
waiting times uh have risen to it to to
a situation which is completely
unacceptable but the other thing that
struck me about this story in the Metro
that is that we've had the busiest time
ever for May in accidental emergency now
we know that there are a huge winter
pressures on uh the NHS but to have the
the record busiest time in May is quite
extraordinary that that really needs a
deep dive into it to work out what Nerf
is going on now one of the factors when
it comes to that waiting list must be
reaction by doctors and to and also by
nurses and the strike action which we're
all familiar with but in any event these
are statistics that will really cause
the government real concern and of
course Ordinary People who are desperate
to have those operations want those
Cancer Treatments need that speed
especially in things like cancer but
also want to want to know what's going
on in a e and why there are record
levels prevailing of people going into
failing Nancy and minesh Patel of
MacMillan cancer support is quoted as
Saying A system that cannot cope is
letting down thousands
um its vital government prioritizes
Cancer Care
yes and I think we've all got friends or
family who were suffering from this who
who simply aren't getting the treatment
they need and actually many many who
have died or are dying because they
weren't diagnosed enough or they weren't
treated enough well their dreams didn't
move a Lot quickly enough this is a
really really enormous problem and it is
a political problem it needs a political
solution it needs the people who work in
our NHS to be treated correctly to be
paid properly to be respected to be
encouraged into the job because let's be
honest not many people want to do these
jobs anymore for obvious reasons it
needs a complete stranger approach but
actually the least interesting thing for
the vast majority of people is the fact
that the prime ministers failing on his
targets because actually if you're
waiting one of the 7.4 million people
waiting for an operation all you care
about is that you need it done or you
need it done quickly and it's a
political football that should never
have been allowed to become called
football it's far too important the NHS
is the thing that people value most
about this country every single survey
seems to come back and say how much will
of our NHS and yet Tim is being let down
under 7.4 million people desperately
desperately needing treatment and not
getting it
and it'll take us to the guardian and
the picture there of the um Smoky Haze
this is from the wildfires raging in
Canada and at some points during the day
you could hardly see the the sky scene
because of the the depth of the The Fog
and this this isn't something that's
just today this has been going on for
numbers of the number of days and it's
not likely to shift for a number of days
and there have been these appalling
wildfires and this is the consequence
and of course it's not just New York I
mean there are pictures obviously of
other places other cities like
Washington so it's I mean look at the
scale of this and I think the thing
that's really concerning people you know
even more than the fact that it has
produced its extraordinary levels of
pollution as we can see
um in photographs in New York uh
Washington and other places but it's the
fact that those wildfires have come
earlier than they would otherwise don't
have done and then that adds to this
real I mean there's just no debate about
it you know we are we're basically
destroying our planet you know what more
evidence do people want and we can talk
about it till the cows come home but
actually we have there's no debate again
in my mind that we have got to start
proper serious action indeed Anna and
Nancy thank you both we shall see you in
the 11 o'clock hour
let's have a look at the weather in the
meantime
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
warmer humid air and some heavy thundery
showers will move into the south for the
weekend most places will have a dry
start tomorrow despite plenty of cloud
across Britain about the far Southwest
we'll see a few blustery showers
Cornwall looks most at risk the cloud
will quickly clear during the morning to
leave plenty of sunshine but some North
Sea coastal areas will stay dull it'll
also be patchy Cloud over the south of
Ireland and a Southwest England to bring
further well-scattered showers overall
it'll be windier and warmer than today
but cool again where Cloud lingers near
eastern coast the afternoon will bring
more of the same but the shower risk
will extend further north across Island
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you